Nấm nướt tại sau hay tại đi tại lại,
đu gọi đầu rất thường xuyên gâu thích chất là cái khoảng của việc tế bảo ra đầu
bị thay thế và bỏng cho quả nhanh,
nguyên nhân chùiếu đến từ sự kết hợp rất dầu thừa
và một loại nấm mẹn tự nhiên,
mà lát sê dà, sống trên ra đầu,
tinh trạng này gặng gung phát mạnh hơn khi nhau người chọn dầu gốc dẻ tiền
thang công nghiệp sản xuất đại trà,
có hiểu ứng sạch gầu nhanh,
tuy nhiên có hợp chất tạo bỏng phó chất đại dưới mạnh sẽ phá vỡ độ
và bỏng phé khác và lúc mạng bảo vệ tự nhiên chết ra đầu bị thích ứng,
khu ra bằng nướt ngay sức dội hơn,
chỉ sâu thế ra hắn hắn sự dụng về lâu dài,
nó còn có thể rất đến lắm ra đường nặng,
vương lăng lông và gây dụt tóc có thể tổng diền chiều để khóc phục,
nể dụng mấy thư dụng tình được lúc sản phẩm phu hơn với tình trạng nước trên
bà có thể thang khảo dầu gốc chiên mốt trở giảm gầu nướt biểu kè phá gà,
sạch gầu nên sâu vài ngày tuy cơ điện mỗi người,
đặc biệt đây là loại dụng gôi không phải khu tóc và có khả năng ước chế vì nấm cây gầu,
không loại lại khi đánh đồng hành tình sạch và quan trất tiến tiến phía rốt thôn,
ô làm in tăng độc thằng và vì nấm mà là SESIA,
nguyên nhìn chính gây nền gầu,
gây thậu với bê hết á dút làm sạch bầy gầu bòng chóc dông nhớn,
chỉ dễ hà thù hồ,
phương hợp bầy loại thảo mục,
sức lạnh ra đầu tổn thương,
bầy gầu nướt gây ra,
phó trở tóc chất khỏe,
cây thịt nữ dụng cho nên người là dải pháp suo bạng vừa sẽ gầu ăn gòn vừa
sức tóc mềm vừa thông loại tình trạc phó trông,
không tổn hại sao đầu,
lành tính cho mọi thấp dụng xa đồng nhẹ gàm
và thậm chí cả vinh ra tinh bá thư điện,
bớt dụng được hăng ai để cây thiết,
bây giờ khai đã được cửa nghiệm dịch trân lợp mếng dụng tâm,
bây giờ khó tất cả bà,
bà chung cân cường dựng thút,
mì thầm thầm phủ hồ chình liên và đã khó rất nhiều lực bán với đánh táp hốn trộm chính trình
hằm sau.
Đà phần khách hàng phản hủ sạch cầu nhanh tóc mềm vừa thông cần thiêm dụng xa,
dùng thay thế lương dầu hộ hẳng ai lộn xa là tình trạc mất tính nữ,
không có các cái cải thiện nữ qua,
thậm chí nữ trọc xai thương pháp sẽ kuyến tình trạc,
đái đi tải lại và trường đến lặng hơn thế nên,
nữ bạn chăng cập gầu, viêm ra tiếp bá hay lắm ra đầu,
hay trọng dài pháp ăn gói,
khó hàu bên vững nưu dầu của điều kè phà mà,
để tránh mùi nhằm hằng ra,
hằng ngày kếm chức lượng,
bắt có thể lấy xanh phần tại ghi đô này nhé.